pour parler de réinventer décote
voilà deux images une image d'abidjan en
1960 il me donne une image d'abidjan en
2016 ce qu'il faut noter sur cette image
c'est qu'à l'époque en 1966 la côte
d'ivoire avait une vraie vision du
développement et de la direction dans
laquelle voulait aller avec ses port
bouet je sais pas si tout le monde a
reconnu mais force est de constater que
50 ans plus tard 2016 voilà en fait quel
est le résultat de cette vision
tout simplement parce qu'elle n'a pas
été appréhendé la pt n'a pas continué
d'être entretenue et ceci pour nous
amener à une époque post crise disons en
2011 2012 ou en tant qu architecte avec
mon associé guillaume koffi
nous étions vraiment très boosté par ce
nouvel élan de la côte d'ivoire nous
sommes dit ah c'est vraiment l'époque on
va pouvoir faire comme avant à voir ce
développement à nouveau ou la codi va
avoir un développement du logement de
l'architecturé structurés sauf que nous
n'avions pas compter avec le fait que le
temps politique est différent du temps
du privé et que là où le politique en
fait tu regardes macro on va regarder
par exemple plan directeur nous nous
étions plutôt dans l'urgence du micro
dans l'urgence de rapporter pouvoir
apporter des solutions qui nous permette
d'avoir non pas de logement mais
logement pour 10000 à 15000 voire
cinquante mille personnes
et cette situation cette divergence de
vision en fait nous amener quelque part
une forme de frustration et nous sommes
dit il est peut-être temps de retourner
à ce que nous savons faire réellement
c'est à dire l'architecturé est ce que
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas beaucoup
de gens pensent que l' architecture
s'est dessiné deux volets bâtiment mais
pour nous l'architecturé c'est pouvoir
anticiper sur un certain nombre de
questions de société qui se pose donc
par exemple
nous sommes quand nous travaillons nous
sommes des concepteurs et pour concevoir
il faut que nous fassions appel à un
certain nombre de principes
un certain nombre de compétences nous
sommes administrateurs artistes
conseiller familial contre leurs
dépenses coordinateur professeur
documentaliste paysagiste en patron
sociologue et accessoirement orateurs
public donc c'est cette dynamique en
fait qui nous a fait remarquer qu'en
fait la conception la même logique de
conception qui nous permettait de
réaliser une maison c'est cette même
logique de conception qu'il fallait
mettre en oeuvre pour réaliser un
écosystème réalise l écosystème qui
allait nous permettre finalement
d'exprimer notre réelle vision et c'est
comme ça que nous sommes devenus
architectes développeurs et pour nous
acheter que développeur c'était
véritablement l'opportunité de contrôler
la vision depuis l'idée jusqu'au produit
fini est justement dans ce processus
acquérir une véritable indépendance et
ne pas être nécessairement lié à des
financements ou une volonté politique et
c'est comme ça que en 2012 nous avons
initié notre première opération qui
s'appelle l'aise dans chocolat
pour nous il était important dans cette
opération de pouvoir promouvoir des
visions de ce que c'est que habiter
autrement
évidemment c'est d'un premier projet un
premier projet résidences de luxe avec
32 logements 14 maisons et 18
appartements qui nous a permis de
pouvoir entamer cette réflexion sur la
vie des autres bombes et pour nous
habiter autrement qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement habiter autrement
c'est habité ensemble pour pouvoir
préserver l'intimité de chacun c'est
habité groupe et pour ne pas gaspiller
l'espace habité contemporain pour être
bien dans son époque
habiter en collectif pour partager nos
cultures habité personnalisé pour
s'adapter à la vie qui change et habiter
plus haut pour stopper l'étalement
urbain
dans une ville comme abidjan habiter
durable pour économiser l'énergie et
habiter écologique pour préserver la
planète
mais évidemment il fallait mettre en
oeuvre toutes ces belles idées et nous
avons commencé en fait part ce qui est
le coeur de notre métier donc
l'architecturé l'idée de l' architecture
dont nous avons commencé avec un
principe qui nous est cher c'est la
densification
abidjan est une ville qui s'étale et et
s'étalent à perte de vue et dans un
contexte tel il est difficile d'amener
de l'électricité de l'eau de gérer les
déchets de gérer la circulation de
d'éviter les embouteillages
quand on s'étale et donc pour nous il
est important dans un premier projet de
luxe de créer une forme d'émulation
si par exemple vous avez de l'habitat de
luxe qui se déploie sur 400 mètres
carrés
évidemment l'habitat on va dire
l'habitat disons papa de luxe mais celui
qui vient ensuite ne va pas vous
demander plus de 400 mètres carrés dont
il est important de créer une forme
d'émulation et donc vous voyez ici en
fait notre projet le projet chocolat au
milieu qui est relativement dense par
rapport à l'environnement dans lequel il
se situe qui est jusqu'à aujourd'hui
encore quand même relativement vide
vous avez par exemple dans ce quartier
des gens qui ont l'habitude de vivre sur
des terres peu 2000 mètres carrés alors
il était important pour nous de montrer
qu'il y avait une alternative à ces
modes de vie là alors au delà de
l'habiter danse il ya aussi la façon
d'habiter d'oncle elle habitait durable
pour nous il était important par exemple
dans ce projet de pouvoir introduire des
choses comme le double vitrage pour
préserver pour isoler en fait les
espaces et diminuer les consommations
d'énergie il est important d'avoir des
astuces qui nous permettait de créer des
ventilation naturelle à l'intérieur des
espaces et il était aussi important dans
un pays comme la côte d'ivoire de
pouvoir créer un microclimat par
l'utilisation de
végétation de la végétation qui existe
et qui est gratuite pour tout le monde
dans les principes de d'habitat que nous
allions créer et aussi au delà de ces
principes de durabilité nous avons
utilisé une astuce ici qui nous a permis
en fait d'éviter d'avoir des voitures à
l'inter de la concession et les maîtres
tout en sous sol avec une liaison
directe vers les espaces privés au delà
en fait de cette liaison directe c'était
pour pouvoir récupérer un espace
important dans la concession qui allait
servir à l'ensemble de la concession
donc on ne va plus être effectivement
une consommation personnelle de l'espace
mais on va mutualiser l'espace pour
pouvoir tous ensemble bénéficier d'
espaces plus grandes espaces plus vers
des espaces plus agréable alors
évidemment utiliser les espaces communs
nous amène à mutualiser les choses et
dans la mutualisation il y a ce principe
d'utiliser les choses en commun mais
également de mutualiser les besoins donc
par exemple ça va être un groupe
électrogène pour l'ensemble de la
concession
ça va être également un seul gardiennage
une seule sécurité pour l'ensemble de la
concession
ça va être un jardinier pour tout le
monde ça va être l'utilisation des
espaces communs ensemble et tout ceci en
fait nous avons réalisé permet de faire
des économies intéressantes c'est à dire
par exemple si vous avez vu dans une
concession où tout est mutualisé vous
n'avez pas besoin d'avoir propre garde
jardinier votre propre gardien et donc
du coup quand on fait un cumul et qu'on
regarde vos charges en fin de mois
on est bien plus c'est bien plus
avantageux que d'avoir chacun son propre
jet jardiniers ou verdien et c'est donc
aussi ça nous permet de revenir à une
idée qui a été perdu dans abidjan ni d'y
et qu'il faut recommencer à penser les
espaces ensemble à vivre ensemble à
pouvoir se connaître en tant que voisin
plutôt que vivre chacun derrière son mur
alors comment est ce que nous avons de
plus mettre ce rêve finalement en forme
évidemment c'est bien beau d'avoir
l'idée mais si vous n'avez pas d'argent
vous pouvez rien y faire
alors nous avions eu la chance à
l'époque en 2006 de pouvoir acquérir une
parcelle de foncier à la riviera golf
à l'époque ça coûtait très peu cher
c'était vingt mille francs dus par
l'ajef vingt mille francs déclarés et au
moment où nous commencions l'opération
cette valeur avait été multipliée par
six
donc si vous arrivez avec un terrain qui
vaut quand même quelque chose vers le
banquier il va vous écouter plus que si
vous n'avez rien et l'autre paramètre
nous avons décidé d'utiliser celle
utilisée la vente en l'état futur
d'achèvement
au début quand nous sommes allés vers
les banquiers personne n'y croyait tout
le monde trouvait que c'était un projet
ambitieux mais pas réalisable
jusqu'au moment où on décide d'utiliser
les mécanismes de la vefa vente en état
futur d'achèvement pour mettre le
principe suivant place qu'est ce que
nous avons fait nous avons demandé aux
banques d'emprunter uniquement la moitié
du besoin financement justement pour
limiter les risques
et avec cette moitié de financement nous
avions commencé le chantier et le
chantier a permis de booster la
commercialisation
donc ce qui fait que en cours de
chantier nous avons pu commercialiser
suffisamment pour pouvoir finalement
combler le besoin en financement donc
une fois que nous avons résolu notre
problème de financement il fallait
construire mais à construire comment
nous qui estimant que le véritable
avantage de de l'architecte qui devient
développeurs c'est le contrôle de toute
la chaîne il fallait que nous mêmes nous
construisions et comment est ce que nous
avons fait nous avons décidé de fédérer
un certain nombre de jeunes entreprises
avec lesquelles nous travaillons jeu des
entreprises ivoiriennes et pour pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre notre vision et dans
cette vision il fallait contrôler les
coûts premièrement parce que quand vous
êtes architecte simple effectivement
c'est le client qui paye
mais si vous êtes architectes
développeurs c'est à vous de contrôler
les coûts pour que votre pression soit
viable et donc c'est ce que nous avons
fait mais il fallait également contrôler
la qualité
pourquoi parce que nous avions une image
très nette de ce que nous voulions et il
fallait que le résultat final soit
conforme à cette image là et le fait
d'avoir construit en fait nous a permis
de
fédérer un certain nombre de compétences
locales et nous avons été très surpris
très agréablement surpris de se rendre
compte qu'en fait nous avons réussi à
faire cette opération avec des
entreprises des jeunes petite entreprise
100% hybride et pour nous ça c'était
véritablement un succès mais une fois
que vous avez effectivement commencé à
construire il faut vendre et comment est
ce que vous vendez une maison de luxe
sur 400 mètres carrés alors que la norme
en fait c'est d'avoir ton qui pour un
prix équivalent sur un terrain de 1200 à
1500 m mais nous avons décidé qu'en fait
nous le vendions pas des mètres carrés
et que nous vendions plutôt une qualité
architecturale donc avec le temps que
nous avons passé à développer ses
produits
c'est un produit dont la conception a
pris plus de deux ans nous nous sommes à
+ également sur la qualité des espaces
certes le terrain est petit mais quelle
qualité architecturale
on donne qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir
comme titre d' espace qui finalement
donnera envie à la personne qui vient
acheter
nous avons aussi tabler sur la
consommation d'énergie
comment faire en sorte que nos logements
consomment moins que la plupart des
logements en meilleur une climatisation
performante en mettant des équipements
électroménagers de basse consommation et
en ayant une température à l'intérieur
qui évite la climatisation et c'est
ainsi que nous arrivons aujourd'hui à
avoir des factures qui sont bien en
dessous des factures
d'autres manquons ojeda et on a eu ce
compliment d'un de nos clients qui
disent aimer votre opération finalement
c'est le droit à la paresse parce que on
peut finalement payer nos charges à la
fin du mois et pouvoir bénéficier en
fait de toutes ses commodités
il a fallu effectivement que nous
allions au delà de notre trop gâté vais
mettre en place un syndic
tout simplement pour s'assurer que le
produit une fois qu'on leur ai livré
pourrait continuer de vivre et bien
alors évidemment fort de ce succès qui
nous qui nous a boostés dont on est et
on était tous contents mais une espèce
de satisfaction en demi teinte parce
qu'on se dit mais finalement on a
produit 32 logements de luxe dans une
ville qui a besoin plutôt de 32 mille
logements économiques par an et donc
pour nous le challenge devait continuer
et nous sommes dit que la démarche nous
avions entamé devrait pouvoir non
seulement être contagieuse c'est à dire
pouvoir se transmettre éventuellement à
d'autres architectes mais également il
fallait qu'on apprenne à travailler sur
des espaces plus grands
évidemment ça va dans une certaine
logique si vous avez fait 32 logements
après vous pouvez passer à une centaine
de logements
après 100 logements ou peut-être passer
à 1000 logements avant d'avoir à pouvoir
produire 5000-10000 donc une certaine
logique de progression est notre
prochain projet qui s'appelle à bata
village est un projet nous n'avons voulu
tester au delà de des expérimentations
nous avons fait avec chocolat d'autres
principes comme principe de mixité
sociale
donc on va avoir sur ce ce développement
différentes typologies d'appartements et
différentes typologies de maison qui
permettront en fait à différentes
couches sociales de la société
ivoirienne de cohabiter et d'avoir en
commun leur espace
commun leurs espaces extérieurs de sorte
à ce que les uns et les autres s'habitue
à pouvoir partager l'espace résiduelles
l'espace extérieur plutôt que de
s'enfermer chez soi et d'avoir une
conception relativement fermé des choses
et au delà de cette mixité sociale nous
avons aussi voulu une mixité
fonctionnelle
donc ça veut dire qu'on va voir non
seulement des maisons des appartements
mais nous allons également introduire du
tertiaire nous allons introduire du
commerce ou à introduire des bureaux de
sorte à ce que l'abidjanaise puisse
commencer à envisager sa vie
différemment qui ne soit pas dans un
mouvement pendulaire quitté à bata bras
les hauts plateaux mais qu'on puisse
éventuellement travailler à proximité du
lieu où on habite
et tout ça bien sûr dans un
environnement qui devra continuer d'être
un menu nous allons tester
bien sûr avec les chaînes avec 180
logements peut tester ce qu'on appelle
la mobilité douce c'est à dire continuer
à faire disparaître les véhicules comme
nous l'avons fait dans l'autre projet et
promouvoir plutôt le déplacement à pied
les déplacements à vélo
donc parce que nous pensons nous croyons
à ces valeurs nous pensons que
effectivement l'abidjan de demain devra
pouvoir incarner ces valeurs là et nous
avons même l'ambition de pouvoir
justement avec une avec un tel quartier
pouvoir introduire ce qu'on appelle le
tri sélectif et donc se familiariser
petit à petit à trier nos ordures et
éventuellement pourquoi pas à utiliser
les ordures des ordures organique pour
pouvoir faire ce qu'on appelle du
compost et aidera alors donc tout ceci
en fait pour nous montrer qu' il est
possible en fait de faire des choses une
fois que l'on commence à réfléchir à
penser avec une certaine dose
d'innovation
par derrière et pour nous qui sommes
architectes il a toujours été important
l'acompte la conception et toujours ce
qui a guidé nos actions et je pense que
nous pouvons faire ce que nous voulons
dans la vie à partir du moment où nous
avons une démarche de conception ou nous
réfléchissions à un certain nombre de
choses surtout dans des environnements
comme les nôtres où parfois il semble
difficile de contrôler en fait ce qui se
passe aux alentours de nous de contrôler
par exemple d'autres possibilités
d'accès au crédit de contrôler nos
espaces nous environnement de contrôler
la qualité de ces espaces et ça me
ramener un petit peu à une phrase que
mon père ma maman m'a dit un jour à
l'époque où on était en pleine crise en
côte d'ivoire et je me plais ni peu de
de l'attitude de nos dirigeants
politiques qui m'a dit tu sais mon fils
il ne faut jamais te préoccuper de ce
que tu ne contrôles pas et quelque part
c'est cette fois j'ai envie de 2,2 de la
halle à redire en fait à la sauce de
réinventons nos codes et pour moi c'est
de dire il faut au contraire que nous
nous préoccupions des choses que nous
contrôlons et c'est ça en fait pour moi
qui est le premier pas en fait quand il
s'agit de réinventer les codes
merci